hi there steve kaufman here you know i
think many people want to learn
a number of things including they want
to learn languages
i think a lot of people don't know how
to learn
so my video today is about learning how
to
learn remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe you can click on the
bell and you'll get notifications
now what i'm about to say is very much
personal how i view learning based on
my experience watching others what works
for me
and the reading that i have done about
how the brain
learns and i'm not a neuroscientist i
often
quote manfred spitzer leonen
you know brain research and the school
of life and i mean i just looked into my
library you know
uh the mind of the brain which talks
about how
we can will our brain to do certain
things
the right mind i mean there's lots of
books i've read on the brain
my view is that to be successful at
learning in order in other words to
learn how to learn
you have to have uh an image a vision of
how
you think your brain learns
um my vision of how my brain learns
is based on my experience and what i've
read
on how the brain learns so i'm persuaded
that our brain and manfred spitzer
refers to this quite often
our brain starts to form neural
connections
between connections between neurons
based on our experience and
as long as the brain is gaining new
experience it's
forming new neural connections so it's
constantly learning
that the brain cannot do otherwise than
learn
um however as
spitzer points out the brain is not very
good at learning
details because whatever it learns it
forgets
so that the specific things that we are
trying to learn
which might be a list of vocabulary
items it might be grammar rules it might
be something else
those things we can retain them for a
short time and then they're quickly
forgotten
but the underlying patterns
in those bits of information is what the
brain is very good at
putting together and that's why the
if we weren't able to do that we would
be dealing with every situation in life
as if it was the first time we ever you
know encountered that
uh situation whereas in fact what
happens is the brain
builds up these patterns to enable us to
navigate our way through life that's
true of
everything that happens to us in life
it's true in
language learning so my focus in
language learning as i've said many
times
is to expose myself to as much
language if i'm learning a language
language content as possible
and not to worry too much about specific
rules
specific words uh you know i saw a thing
the other day
teachers on twitter were saying you know
should we teach
kids these words are those words you
know two different word lists
it's not up to the teacher to decide
which words
the kids should learn or to attempt to
teach these words
all the teacher can do is to provide an
environment
where the learner is motivated is
interested
because it's something of interest and
by being exposed to this
over and over again gradually certain
patterns
will form in the brain and so
you know i'm quite content in my arabic
i'm not ever going to test myself i'm
just happy to
listen to uh you know a transcript of an
of a podcast uh go through it maybe
in sentence view maybe in full text view
listen to it read it of course if i
spoke more i'd get better at speaking
but let's not underestimate the power of
listening and reading because
when you are reading you're interpreting
symbols and converting those
symbols into meaning that is a powerful
activity that is
active that's not just passive uh
now we know for example you've
undoubtedly heard that say a london taxi
driver has to memorize it has to get to
know all the little streets and
alleyways in london
that part of his brain a certain part of
his brain grows
as a result so all of our activity even
what we might consider to be passive
activity in fact is creating
changes in the brain learning is about
change
learning is not about being able to
produce something now
pl you know here's a test get it right
it's not about that
it's about gradually exposing yourself
to
a variety of stimulus allowing your
brain to form
patterns and and having the confidence
that the brain
is doing its job it's not going to do it
you know according to some timetable
that you set for the brain
the brain learns but the brain learns
slowly that's what spitzer says
similarly even if you are an adult
say or older person like me and maybe
you create new neural connections more
slowly or the plasticity of the brain is
not
as quick as it used to be when you were
12.
on the other hand the brain is bringing
in this information
relating it to things that you already
know experience
life experience knowledge vocabulary
you know knowledge about different
content areas and stuff
all of which makes it easier in some
ways for you to learn but the process
is essentially the same and you have to
have confidence
in that ability once you've had
enough exposure to the language your
brain has started to form certain
patterns
if you want to look at some rules to
remind you of things or to point some
things out that you didn't notice
that's fine but the idea that somehow
the brain can absorb
specific rules or specific lists that
that they can that the brain can
deliberately learn these things at one
sitting
i think has been increasingly debunked
so
learning to learn means learning to
learn in a way
that corresponds to how your brain
learns or how you would like to think of
your brain learning
because it's also very subjective and so
putting pressure on yourself to
you know to to learn certain things i
don't want to learn them now
that is not a very effective way of
learning if you can
find a way to enjoy in the case of
languages
content or if you're trying to learn
through the language about the history
of a certain period
if you can get a variety of different
content
items on a related theme
where to some extent related vocabulary
is going to appear
and a subject that you are gradually
becoming familiar with
you know shows up in all of these
different stories
uh all of that is going to help you
learn so so you have to have this
approach of just
letting it come to you having the
confidence that you can do it
um enjoying the process and
trusting your brain i think a big part
of
learning how to learn is to to learn
to trust your brain and don't worry
whether you got 5 out of 10 on a drill
or whether you remembered a certain you
know word list
if the language comes into you and you
keep staying with it
you're going to learn that's what you
need to know that's to me
learning how to learn don't let the
teacher
impose this word list or these stories
get out and explore let the brain enjoy
the language
let yourself enjoy the language and the
brain will learn
and i think learning how to learn is is
no more complicated than that
yes there are details on where you can
go find
you know content of interest and people
can help you find that
or how do you how to utilize you know
google translate or text to speech or
netflix or youtube or link or any of the
other
you know online dictionaries and
different apps and
all that kind of stuff but those are the
details again
learning how to learn to me means having
a a
sort of a vision of yourself as a
learner
which corresponds to how the brain
learns
and just sit back and enjoy the process
and you will
succeed you will succeed you have to
believe that you're going to succeed
don't second-guess yourself and so
that's what i wanted to talk about and
um
i'm going to leave you with two videos
that i did uh
over the past few years which touch on
the same theme because
more or less the the theme is constant
you have to believe in yourself and you
have to enjoy the process